what is Oprah's one word so as you guys
probably know by now I've written a book
called your one word which is about
finding your one core value that makes
you come alive that represents who you
are when you understand what you stand
for then you can build a life and a
business with meaning and purpose and
that is valuable and so I thought what
might be interesting is showing off some
famous entrepreneurs and understanding
what is there one word that makes them
tick first Oprah Winfrey what is your
brand do you think oh I'm the love bread
oh we all darling you'd like to shower
love around and yeah it's really that's
what it is I am the love and love brand
that's what I'd like Barry White was the
love god you're the love brand I'm the
love brand because ultimately everything
that I'm saying whether it's in my
magazine
whether it's Gayle on the radio or
whether it's the Oprah Winfrey Show and
now everything about the channel own
it's about opening your space your heart
space so that you can love more you know
that's really all money is for money's
worth nothing if it can't buy you the
opportunity to love more thank you guys
so much for watching I hope you enjoyed
the clip I'd love to know what your one
where it is if you want to leave it down
in the comments below again I appreciate
your viewership I believe in you I hope
you continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
and I'll see you soon